okay so though i've already done a full
breakdown on the doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness trailer i had to
go back to it after re-watching the
teaser there's so many things in it that
i only caught after multiple viewings
and this might be my first ever things i
missed video throughout it we're going
to be discussing some of the insane
hidden details that are peppered
throughout and also going over what we
think the storyline will be i just want
to get straight into it but if you enjoy
the video then please smash that thumbs
up button and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day without the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
multiverse of madness
okay so the super bowl tv spot actually
contains a lot of shots that aren't in
the full trailer because of this i think
we can get a much better grasp of the
storyline and what defender strange's
role is in it we get a full look at the
variant and in the background of this
shot you can see the ribbon-like monster
that strings up america chavez in the
main one defender strange can also be
seen hurtling through a portal which is
when the mcu version wakes up and i
believe that he snapped out of his sleep
because the defender one dies also huge
apology for the tv spot quality i tried
finding a good trailer but there isn't
one this video is where the real
nightmare begins anyway the trailer has
the mcu version travelling to an
alternate reality in which he summoned
before the illuminati who seemed to be
led by professor x in this world strange
stands before a statue of himself and i
think this is actually dedicated to
defender strange who died in the opening
of the movie now later on in the tv spot
we see an undead zombie version of
strange that ends up being one of the
final shots in the trailer whilst it's
been theorized that this is the evil
strange we meet in the sanctuarium i
actually think that this is defender
strange brought back to life his
clothing is very similar to what we see
on the statue and it also appears in
line with the one from the tv spot very
much seems like wanda is the main
villain and potentially she uses the
dark hold in order to resurrect him
alongside him are several dark spirits
which one could have also brought in
with the spells of the dark hold we know
from the end of one division that she
was studying it and later on in the
video we'll talk about how she might be
inside a chaos dimension of her own
making now in the tv spot we see a scene
in which a variant christine stands in a
lab with america chavez in a glass cage
behind her we know that this is a
variant because she has red hair whereas
the one in the mcu timeline doesn't have
this maybelline look sure she could have
dyed it but the mc version is also
getting married in the movie or as this
one doesn't have a ring on her finger at
least i don't think she does try to look
him but i can't say anything now perhaps
she was in a relationship with defender
strange and due to his death she's now
tied up in the mcu one coming into her
reality this reality appears to be the
same as the ultronbot dimension and i
think that when strange is taken before
the council that america will be taken
here we can catch one of the bots
walking around and therefore it all kind
of ties together and i'm just being
captain obvious now pay attention to
this glass prison as when we get a zoom
in on wanda's face later you can catch
this area in the reflection of her eyes
with a focus on the prison itself
standing in the cell to the right is a
figure that looks a lot like america who
will probably still be trapped in the
one that we see behind christine i think
that wonder will very much be trying to
harvest america's powers so that she can
travel through the multiverse at will
just like she can this will mean that
she'll be able to find a dimension in
which her kids are still alive which
could be the moment that we see the two
wonders coming face to face although it
does seem like wonder is somewhat calm
at the beginning of the trailer if you
pay close attention you can see that her
garden is in fact a lie later on when
wanda gives a speech about how she's
seen as the enemy whilst strange is a
hero pay close attention to the clothes
that he's wearing strange has the exact
same one zone that he has in the garden
and therefore i think that these scenes
are taking place at the same time
they're shot in a very similar manner
and when you place the scene side by
side it just becomes obvious the west
view was very much an illusion in one
division and she painted it out as the
perfect place to raise a family in
however it was really a prison for all
those inside who were forced to follow
routines in order to prop her up i think
this entire garden is very much the same
and that she's continuing this illusion
so that anyone who approaches her thinks
that she's fine however the illusion
appears to drop at some point and it's
likely when they get onto the subject of
altering reality now the line about him
breaking the multiverse and still being
seen as a hero is a bit of a weird one
and potentially this ties into the end
of no way home though peter was
forgotten people still remember
spider-man and the public may know that
strange pulled across the villains and
heroes in the film even if they don't
remember parker now one of the big
talking points online is who is the
mysterious burning figure that fights
wonder when she blasts the character you
can catch some statues with wings on
their back which are also present in the
scene in which strange is taken him by
the sentry drones therefore i think that
wonder ambushes this reality due to this
moment and the one later on where we do
a close-up on her eyes now as for the
figure the main theories are that it's
tom cruise playing superior iron man
monica rambo or her mother maria it
really could be any of them but
personally i'm leaning more towards
maria potentially she could have taken
the flight that captain marvel did in
the mcu and this would have given her
the powers instead of carol thus in this
reality she might have become captain
marvel and in the comics the rambos also
done the moniker
tom cruise would also be great though
and in case you don't know he was
originally rumored to be playing tony
stark when they were first trying to
develop an iron man movie it would be
such a cool throwback to bring him
across and as cruz hasn't started a
superhero film before i think that would
be amazing now beyond this other little
details in the trailer include america
and stephen traveling through several
portals at one point they pass a
landfill with dinosaurs and this could
actually be the savage land from marvel
comics this is a location that's been
completely uncharted and it's where
prehistoric life managed to find refuge
whilst the rest of the dinosaurs were
wiped out there's been several big
battles that have happened there
including secret invasion which is an
upcoming disney plus show i did discuss
that when they go through one reality
that their faces change into squares and
i said in my last breakdown that this
was similar to a scene in infinity war
then i'll splash tracks at one point
with the reality stone and this turns
them into cubes which is what they look
like here however this could be a nod to
the famous house of m cover which is
people's faces turning into blocks as
wonder warps reality i think this might
be a dimension where everything is just
a cube of some sort as we can catch what
appears to be buildings in the
background that have this style to them
as they enter a portal you can also
catch an animated almost comic book
world that they're about to go into
slowing the footage down you might
notice that they start to change from
their regular looks into more comic book
looking cartoons showing how they alter
as reality does i'd absolutely love it
if they traveled into a comic book
dimension and became 2d characters that
would be such a cool night of the comics
and it would also allow us to see more
of the wacky characters that you can't
pull off in live action just in the same
way that into the spider-verse had
spider-ham this could do a lot of things
with characters who aren't the kinds
that you can see normal movies it really
shows how creative they can get with it
and overall i absolutely love the
trailer i'll probably end up doing
another video at some point because it's
filled with so many things it's one of
the most dense teasers i've ever seen
and now i know a lot of you wanted me to
go straight into moonlight i had to
tackle this first now i'm sure i've
still missed some things so if you
caught anything we didn't then comment
below and let us know we are in a
competition right now giving away three
copies of the june boxer on the 28th of
feb and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the full trailer which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over everything we didn't discuss in
this video and talk about the main plot
points in it so definitely go head over
there right after this i'm using my
professor x powers on you now you better
go do it otherwise i'll make you think
that you're me which is the worst life
that you could ever have cheers see you
on the next one you better go bye
[Music]
you